hey 42 here we humans can build some
pretty spectacular things skyscrapers
monuments and majestic feats of
Engineering just spring from the ground
wherever we settle it's as if we just
can't help but shake a triumphant fist
at the sky before marking our territory
piece of architectural artwork but did
you know that the greatest architects
and designers in the world don't
necessarily work at a desk in a fancy
office to find them in there or
inspiring projects you might have to
take a walk on the wild side here are
seven amazing structures created by
animals in the remote and untamed
wilderness area Wood Buffalo National
Park in Alberta Canada everyone's
favorite semi-aquatic rodents have
banded together to earn their very own
world record since the mid 1970s
generations of beavers have spent their
lives felling trees in preparation for
their magnum opus the world's biggest
Beaver Dam not to be confused with the
quaint little hamlet of Beaver Dam
Alberta although I'm sure they have just
as much to be proud of this impressive
structure was first discovered in 2007
thanks to researchers using Google Earth
yes the dam is so big it can be seen
from space
step aside Great Wall of China it wasn't
until 2014 as an adventurous person made
the journey to see it for themselves
measuring a whopping 850 metres long and
formed from two different dams joined
together
it's a length which earns it the title
of the biggest in the world - beaver
lodges housed the industrious workers
offering a place for them to rest and
celebrate their fine work although
they're not interested in resting for
very long as the beavers continue
developing the dam to this day building
towards another dam under construction
nearby which will add between 50 and 100
meters to the dams total length just
like other enthusiastic record-holders
they're looking to defend their title
and perhaps give some human scale dams a
run for their money
busy as a beaver in
indeed equally as renowned as a beaver
for their work ethic the lowly ant is
capable of lifting objects over ten
times its own weight and building
elaborate communities out of the very
soil beneath you we've all seen ant
hills the little mound of dirt piled
ankle-high
around the entrances and exits of ant
colonies but just how deep do they go
exactly in 2012 the largest known ant
city was unearthed in the country of
Brazil covering an area of five hundred
square feet and plunging 26 feet beneath
the surface based on best estimates it
is presumed that the ant moved nearly 40
tons of soil while excavating the
labyrinthine network of tunnels chambers
and other distinct structures to put
that weight into perspective it would be
the same as the ant shifting a humpback
whale bit by bit to build their home
that's no small feat when the ant city
was discovered the leafcutter ants who
once called it home had long since
abandoned it for greener pastures
though they left behind telltale signs
of how they organized their car system
to which they were bound within the
colony were distinct rubbish heaps where
the refuse generated by the ants would
have been gathered to be removed by
designated garbage handlers Gardens were
dotted throughout for the cultivation of
the edible fungus that the ants
subsisted on besides major thoroughfares
which cut through the heart of the
colony
just like our highways it's eerily
similar to how human society must look
from a bird's eye view and it surely
ranked as one of the most spectacular
feats
ants have ever accomplished so the next
time you've got a magnifying glass and
you're feeling antsy perhaps you should
consider giving a little book as a pass
and find something else to burn not all
termites live in the walls of suburban
homes though that might be hard to
believe at first they would chew their
way through a tree just as soon as they
cause structural damage to your house
but out in the wide open spaces of
nature some termites prefer a little
extra shelter from the elements than
just a lay would bark enter the
my mount towering like a natural
Colossus of Rhodes and filled to the
brim with termite ingenuity and
efficiency reaching heights of up to
nine meters the termites like to test
the limits of their natural engineering
talent though it's even more impressive
when you consider that for an equivalent
human building it would be around two
kilometers tall that's the same as
taking two of Saudi Arabia's one
kilometer high Kingdom Tower and
stacking them termite work together as a
cohesive coordinated unit though they
have no language or method of
communication other than pheromones and
basic physical interactions they are
able to send something as simple as
damage to the outer wall of the mound
and within minutes begin to work
together on repairs if their entire
mound were destroyed it could be
completely rebuilt by the colony within
free mom's all without words or
blueprints being that talented at
construction you'd think that termites
would be esteemed as patron saints of
construction workers everywhere but
sadly the stereotype of termites as
vicious home destroyers lives on to help
control the temperature and allow
airflow throughout the colony
ventilation shafts are built to draw in
fresh air from the outside and the
entire mound is formed to naturally
circulate air when combined with the
insulation offered by the earth around
the nest the termites are able to
maintain a pleasant temperature all year
round with remarkably little temperature
variation just like the people of Coober
Pedy
Australia the brilliant little insects
must know the joys of living entirely
underground just like ants termites
burrow into the soil termites however
choose to build higher instead of deeper
creating monuments which will last at
least until the elements or a malicious
predator brings them down off the coast
of Japan in the mid-90s scuba divers
discovered mysterious patterns in the
silt and sand of the ocean floor
scientists were completely baffled there
were no obvious explanations for the
undersea crop circles that
kept appearing at least at first they
watched and waited for a decade trying
to catch the creator in the act but they
saw nothing it wasn't until they decided
to take note of the unassuming
pufferfish that they finally had their
culprit no more than 12 centimeters long
the tiny puffer fish shaped curious
circles on the sea floor up to 2 meters
in diameter although no one is exactly
certain why the best guess of
well-educated men and women is that the
circles are used as a part of the mating
ritual between male and female
pufferfish instead of a metal ring the
male pufferfish carves a ring into the
rapidly shifting sand beneath the serve
and proudly presents it on a bended fin
to his beloved actually that's rather
romantic when you look at it that way
female pufferfish lay their eggs in the
fine sediment at the center before
turning tail leaving the males to guard
the fertilized eggs for another six days
afterwards counting the week or so it
takes the male to make the damn thing
that means that they spend two weeks on
something that the female uses only for
a day or two at best that's rough the
circles while beautiful are not actively
maintained by the pufferfish and will
wash away soon after their usefulness
has ended however their design takes
into account the constant ebb and flow
of underwater currents with fluid
dynamics test finding that the way they
are shaped actually serves to slow down
the currents as they near the center of
the circle this serves to ensure that
the softest sand at the center which is
reserved for the eggs lasts as long as
it needs to understood by the undertow
of the ocean each circle is a temporary
and delicate work of art which can hold
back the sea itself in order to provide
the best conditions for the next
generation of pufferfish pufferfish are
therefore living proof that spectacular
things can come from the smallest
packages in 2010 after an exceptionally
intense monster
season north eastern Pakistan
experienced widespread flooding that
covered nearly one-fifth of its total
land area many of the frontier provinces
suffered as a result with more than 20
million people displaced as a result of
the surging floodwaters but humans
weren't the only ones driven from their
homes seemingly overnight the trees in
flooded areas were completely cocooned
in spiderwebs yep that's right
spiders fled the waters as well seeking
the highest and driest places available
to them in short order the foliage of
eastern Pakistan took on the appearance
of elaborately wrapped Egyptian mummies
and lots of people who didn't know that
they suffered from arachnophobia figured
it out pretty darn quickly and so there
were white frosted branches as far as
the eye could see
although it's not quite the hell on
earth you might be imagining the creepy
crawly spinning webs in the treetops may
have actually provided a small measure
of disaster relief for the stricken
Pakistani people despite the vast new
plot of standing and stagnant water
there is no complimentary rise in
malaria infections due to what should
have been a booming mosquito population
the best guess is that the spiders were
able to effectively control the
mosquitoes and prevent them from running
rampant across a saturated countryside
not quite the evil eight-legged
abominations you took them for a footing
in Pakistan continues to this day so for
now the spiders continue to weave their
spell over the region there is some
evidence that the webbing covering the
leaves may be having a detrimental
effect on the trees but there simply
aren't any volunteers to clear out the
infestation as long as they're keeping
malaria-ridden mosquitoes at bay I
suspect the Pakistani people will
continue to enforce a status quo between
themselves and their brand-new neighbors
it's a well-known fact that birds prefer
to situate their nests up and away from
prying eyes and feeling pores most are
content to gather twigs together in a
fork of the branches where they can
settle down and perhaps lay an egg or
two in relative obscurity
not so for the Montezuma Aaron pendulum
birds of Central America who prefer a
flashy yet isolated lifestyle the
Magnificent basket-like hanging nests of
the Montezuma are opened Ola are often
seen in single tree set apart from the
rest of the forest the peculiar bird
prefers solitary bases from which to
hang their homes often choosing trees
near wasps nests or other hazards so as
to deter potential predators let the
very poster child of introversion in the
animal kingdom you can almost hear them
saying I built a pretty awesome nest but
don't bother coming to see it they
thrive in the tropical climate around
Nicaragua Northwest in Costa Rica and
parts of Panama and southern Mexico like
most creatures native to the region they
have no qualms about putting on a
display as evidenced by their
conspicuous nests and bright ruddy
plumage look but don't approach is their
Creed and if you prefer not to tango
with wasps you will be wise to heed
their warning north and east of
Australia just off the coast lies the
largest structure made by living
organisms it's far larger than the
world's biggest beaver dam and of course
it's also visible from space yes I'm
talking about the Great Barrier Reef one
of the wonders of the natural world and
home to countless types of fish and
other assorted aquatic creatures a
gorgeous stretch of ocean which spans
more than three hundred and forty-four
thousand square kilometres it covers an
area larger than the United Kingdom
Holland and Switzerland combined it was
officially recognized and protected as
the Great Barrier Reef park by the
Australian Government in 1975 with the
protected status came strict rules and
regulations against human interference
providing unique shelter for migrating
whales and endangered species like the
dugong and the large green sea turtle
thanks to the efforts of
conservationists the Great Barrier Reef
is still a pristine refuge for thousands
of ocean dwelling species in a world
where the ocean seemed to grow more
crowded with each passing decade though
photographs and popular culture might
have you believe that the entire reef is
comprised of
Koral in fact only around 7% of it is
actually made of this colorful reef
builders it is however the largest
collection of coral in the world giving
it the distinction of also being the
largest living structure in a sense
besides the coral reefs other types of
marine habitats like shallow sea grass
fields share the space besides algal and
sponge Gardens just to name a few more
its a flourishing ecosystem and a
priceless investment for scientists and
researchers who study our oceans to find
better ways for us to coexist thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
you